we came together to accomplish a mission
we will be walking around we want to
show the world that with the proper
prosthetic care and on how to care it
makes a big difference in someone's life
[Music]
my name is counter-story I lost my leg
back in 2010 overseas in Afghanistan and
with the United States Marines after my
injury I felt lost and confused a lot of
questions of why why my cell live why am
I here suicidal thoughts which made
waking up every day very difficult being
active for me just became my therapy I
found myself inspiring others and
motivating others to be active as well
currently we're in Ecuador climbing for
range of motion project which is a local
organization providing prosthetic and
orthotic care to countries who don't
have a means to provide such care to
their citizens we have ten to twelve
amputees climbing I Amba volcano we all
come from different backgrounds and all
different injuries to be a part of such
a team to me is very very important and
it's very inspiring
somebody in cayenne Bay from the refuge
will take about 12 hours we have the
equipment and the gear but we have to be
patient and wait for the right weather
to get to the summit safely whether we
some Cayenne bit volcano or not it is
just a small part of what we're here to
do but this climb I hope others will
learn a lot about themselves and their
abilities they can do anything they want
to there's nothing that is impossible
[Music]